since he retired five years ago
Ilyas mattes has been taking care of his
small farm
he now has 20 sheep 17 goats and a dozen
chickens along with fruit trees and a
vegetable garden mattis grew up in Cara
tena and he wants to spend the rest of
his life here in the Peloponnese
mountains he provides fruit for himself
and his family his daughter and
son-in-law are both unemployed we don't
have much money and there's a lot we
can't buy I have enough here to get by
but it's very difficult right now for
people who don't have anything a liter
of milk here an egg there my Tess helps
out when others are struggling more and
more villagers are sharing what they
have the money economy is slowly giving
way to barter a trip to the nearest town
to withdraw cash is hardly worth it you
don't have a car to drive to monopoly
you can't afford to collect your
retirement money a taxi ride alone cost
20 euros motorists don't have money for
gasoline that's why they're organizing
car pools for trips to ATMs doctor's
appointments or the hospital located 70
kilometres away almost everyone here
voted no in the referendum even if Cara
Tina once graced the five thousand
drachma banknote hardly anyone here
wants a return to the old money
we're worried our lives are getting
worse by the day if they find a solution
on Sunday we hope this downturn will
come to an end it's been very painful
things will get really bad if there's no
agreement
Ilia smartest still has hope the former
policeman has lost 1/3 of his pension
since the crisis began he voted for
Alexis Cyprus and still has faith in him
but most of all he believes in himself
maybe better men we capital crowd you
shouldn't expect anything from the
government our government has completely
fallen apart and our leaders have made a
lot of mistakes there's nothing more to
say d-nut boxer a war it seems the
people of kara tina are finding their
own way out of the crisis